what's up everybody welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment we're doing
something a little different too if you
guys know but we have some really
special guests on the show yeah yeah
we're gonna change things up today we're
doing this comic book trivia game with
you know two teams of two here before we
get into these introductions I want to
remind you guys to like our Facebook
page at facebook.com slash awesome comic
show we have new exclusive videos that
go up there every single Thursday so
give us a like well yes okay let's get
into the intro let's go to my left first
thank you so much yeah thanks for coming
on the show really appreciate it no
problem no problem over to my right this
is a guy that has been feuding with in
the starter Craig for like thirty years
now
don't listen give me the game learner's
board James this james rolfe what's up
hey how you doing alright I'm glad you
came on the show yeah I'm glad appeared
and our usuals over here for our regular
a good guy and our good yeah
heather ruse of the ruse yeah yes and
alright so I'm gonna explain the rules
of this game a little bit right now so
let's get the explanation if doesn't
have any questions at this time no okay
so there are two teams of two here I've
set up three categories which three
questions each within them worth 100 200
300 points respectively those categories
are comic books comic book movies and
comic book TV now like jeopardy you can
bounce around to different categories
and point valleys if you get the
question right you can keep going
otherwise the next question choice goes
to the other team your team also has one
lifeline this is very important that you
can use which is to phone a critic where
you don't know the answer will bring up
the nostalgia critic and see it can help
you out when we've gone through all of
our categories we move on to the
lightning round will you choose one
member from each team to individually
answer 15 questions in 60 seconds or
less those questions are extra points
worth 100 each get ready to start yeah
sure all right let's do it
call me a television let's go with
movies alright we played Batman / Bruce
Wayne in 1995 Batman Forever I will be a
Val Kilmer
okay 2012 the amazing spider-man what is
the highest-grossing movie at the box
office
no the Avengers from 2000
we'd be in the show now TV and comic
book strong snow comic books for 100 200
300 100 all right here we go
what is the name of Superman's
super-powered dog Krypto that is correct
oh yeah that's correct
okay recently more acknowledged who is
now credited as the co-creator of Batman
with Bob that's correct
fantastic red tie game folks okay okay
here we go spider-man made his debut and
amazing fantasy number 15 in August I
have no idea why that one keeps popping
my head but I don't think that's right I
know I know
coming from someone who didn't trust
their guts to do it was amazing fantasy
number 15 that was his debut Wow yes go
ahead
I I know mine wasn't right 63 162
shouting beats at you
is currently airing Marvel's agents of
shield in the live-action TV show the
David Banner okay it was okay along with
animation legend Bruce Timm co-created
Batman the Animated
do we want to confirm and call a critic
well yeah guess we haven't called a
critic hello who co-created a Batman the
AMA series with Bruce Timm who is this
this is Andre we did it we did a review
once before we've met before
black married I have no memory of you is
that black guy and it's not Malcolm that
you know yes you're the one I wonder do
you yeah so Batman a miniseries who did
that whit Bruce Timm I believe it was
Paul Dini if if not they have their cool
magic words fits of shadow Paul Dini it
sounds cool okay all right
incorrect name it was just more of a
writer create co-creator of Harley Quinn
great you just saw it it's fantastic
okay so we're gonna go with the team was
down to go first so you guys are down by
three right now so we'll go with you
first now you want the lightning round
questions a or B there's two sets of
questions it's just too generic columns
too yes just go much a-pickin okay
remember you got one minute here okay
and the timing starts I have to read the
first question here we go what symbiote
is the main offspring of venom carnage
Bret what is the name of Chris packs
character in the 2014 film Gardens of
galaxies correctly hum the 1978 super in
the movie theme
I mean it's in the it's in the melody
it's like James you can get other color
was daredevil Supergirl suit originally
yellow dress on what country is Black
Panther problems Conda correct what is
the name of Professor X's school and
x-men Xavier's school for gifted
youngsters correct who plays the flash
on the current live-action TV show the
same name
greca correct what video game developer
was behind the popular Batman Arkham
Asylum
you guys have a total of six you need
for to tie anymore no sorry I think
we're done thanks for thanks for the
call oh I've been on forever okay anyway
are you guys yes how did actress Lynda
Carter transform into Wonder Woman in
1970 TV show which boxer did Superman
fight on the cover of a 1978 elite arena
how many x-men movies has Bryan Singer
directed next to I would've said four
correct what other heroic name is Luke
Cage known as power bands correct and
it's a tie right now one morning guys
win before Captain America what other
superhero did Chris Evans playing the
big screen class No
okay well let me call critic and tell me
once where is this oh this is odd Regan
Oh black nerd Malcolm don't call me like
this it's just it's not worth it no okay
first we need to talked about race
relations second we want good for you
who is this Malcolm and Tamra one call
me again thank you very much for
stopping by anything
there's this guy who got stung by like a
thousand different insects and you wrote
a book about it he deliberately let
himself get stoned by like a thousand
insects and then describes what each
sting feels like and his descriptions
are like outrageous it's like this one
feels like pouring hydrochloric acid on
a paper cut and
descriptions yeah it's like it's it's so
descriptive and yeah wait to see what
this guy's superpowers remember to like
our Facebook page as well Facebook might
concise also come and show you got
pretty sure you know where to find these
guys are Hank so I'll go ahead and check
out black you're coming on YouTube and
semester dark I'm on YouTube all that so
until then I know awesome Facebook that
comes on Sasha Porter and Heather ruse
yeah the Witter and other Bruce fate
nope
Instagram and a trips a check everybody
out on that so I can find me on Twitter
an awesome underscore Walter to with
that means England it doesn't give me a
fun it means the world it's all good
okay until next time I'll talk to you
guys later thank you very much for
joining us and we'll see you next time
all right who is this this this is Andre
thanks still